mit diesen bildern einer
überwachungskamera fahndet die polizei
wolfenbüttel nach einer frau sie wurde
nachts mit hüftlangen jacke und sport
schon erfasst an ihrem körper ein
kleines bündel gepresst nach ein paar
sekunden verschwindet sie wieder aus dem
sichtfeld der kamera die polizei ist
sich sicher die unbekannte frau hat hier
einen erst wenige stunden alten säugling
im arm sitzt das wehrlose baby kurz
darauf in einem garten aus
der fall ereignete sich bereits am 11
anwohner in der straße am pfingstanger
morgens aus ihrem gartenhäuschen ein
leises wimmern entdeckten hier den
kleinen jungen
das baby ist inzwischen bei einer
pflegefamilie untergebracht
hinweise an die polizei unter telefon
05331 9330